yeah so at that point there was no
commitment what do you say to girls that
say you can't do too much for a man
before you have the commitment
i'll actually answer that um
a lot of women
want and this is this is such a huge
women make so many mistakes when it
comes to relationships but one of the
biggest mistakes that women make is not
understanding that they have to audition
for the part women tell well i'm not
going to give him girlfriend benefits
until he makes me my girlfriend well a
guy like me who has options i'm not
going to give you the title of
girlfriend until you can prove that you
can be a girlfriend i'm not going to
give him long-term relationship benefits
without him giving me the long-term
relationship commitment there are more
of you than there are of me so it is on
you to qualify to me
so so at the end of the day women want a
women want to be awarded a part that
they have neither auditioned for nor can
prove that they can play it uh a famous
play i don't know uh the sound of music
right uh i don't know what the the the
the main characters female lead they did
not give that lead to uh they didn't
give that lead i think it might have
been julie andrews in the movie they
didn't give that lead to a woman oh you
know what i think i should play the main
character okay well you have to no no no
no no you need to give me the part no
that is literally women expecting
long-term relationship benefits before
they're actually committed to that's
like that's like someone demanding a
part in a play that they have not
auditioned for look if you want the
title you need to audition for the title
if i can't see a willingness for you to
audition and then the ability to be with
a guy like me then guess what it's going
to remain strictly casual that's just
all there is to it and it's it's funny
women get into
situation chips or entanglements with a
with with guys all the time then they
meet one they really like six seven
eight months down the line they think
well why hasn't eric committed to me
because you have you think that you're
entitled to his commitment you haven't
shown him any sign you haven't shown him
any sign that you want to be in a
relationship other than flapping at the
gums hey i want a relationship actions
speak louder than words don't tell him
you want to be in a relationship show
him because he needs to see that you are
equal to the task because if all you're
doing is yapping at the gums we always
say well i guess she's all talking no
show that's why he keeps banging you and
not committing yeah it is a chicken in
the egg or a chicken and egg argument um
there's a common trope that guy says
like why buy the cat why buy the milk if
the cow is free no why buy the cow
for free yeah it's why buy the cow we
can get the milk for free
no no no no not for sale no why buy the
cow why do we have to buy the cow see we
get the cow to get the milk right
why buy the cow if you can get the milk
for free basic but basically why commit
to a woman when you can just get the sex
without the commitment that's what it is
that's what really what guys say go
ahead continue without please well the
way i had it figured it made sense now
it doesn't so never mind
i was gonna say man taking care of a cow
is unsure well no but your point is
well-founded because taking care of a
woman is a chore but why
but here's the thing women or
women or cows the most valuable ass the
most valuable thing a cow has to offer
is milk right
and so if a man has to buy the cow in
order to get the milk then he is going
to buy the cow back in the day if you
wanted to have sex with a woman you
needed to be married to her well guess
what the advent of feminism uh hormonal
birth control roe v wade was women
now well no now
the point is is that women are giving
away the milk without requiring men to
buy the cow they're giving away their
bodies without requiring commitment and
so guys are like wait a minute you mean
i don't have to be in a committed
relationship to have sex girls are just
giving it away without any sort of
commitment great and then these women on
the back end wonder why guys don't want
to commit to them because you are giving
them the commitment benefits without
actually requiring the commitment that's
why we got these running around
um so
[Music]
sorry sorry
[Music]
okay so um
the the next step so first she has to
make sure she's put in the effort she's
putting in the commitment are there [ __ ]
tests that women commonly do early i've
heard this term
and i don't think i don't know if it's
if women [ __ ] tests like on purpose
because some of the stuff that i hear
guys talk about that are [ __ ] tests i
think they're kind of
on accident to us
it's not on accident it's the way you
guys are designed [ __ ] tests
[ __ ] tests vary depending on the
situation if you're at a bar or club
trying to pick up a woman women [ __ ]
test you on purpose i don't date black
guys answer oh neither do i i mean can
you imagine
dude i get a laugh at that i get a laugh
at that every time
um
when women [ __ ] test you in that social
pua scenario they just want to make sure
that you have experience with women
women in relationships [ __ ] tests on
[ __ ] test on autopilot this is not a bad
thing women have to [ __ ] test what women
are doing here is they're biting the
gold and women have to [ __ ] test their
men every so often to make sure that he
is still the man that that that she fell
in love with um so in relationships
women [ __ ] test on autopilot now there's
a big difference between [ __ ] tests and
disrespect if a [ __ ] if a supposed [ __ ]
test makes you feel upset or angry
that's not a [ __ ] test that's disrespect
but for men to not expect a woman a
woman who doesn't test a man is not
interested in a man you can walk up to a
girl and start chatting her up and blah
blah blah oh man she hasn't tested me
then you go in for the number close and
she tells you well i have a boyfriend or
well blah blah blah blah and you're like
what the hell she never [ __ ] tested you
because she never was interested in you
in the first place
women
women will [ __ ] test men as a in
relationships women will indirectly [ __ ]
test men as a matter of
reconfirmation rather than
disqualification now there are
impassable [ __ ] tests at which point
your woman has already lost respect for
you the the relationship is likely going
to be over but [ __ ] tests are a good
thing if your woman if your woman is not
[ __ ] testing you in a relationship it
means one of two things either number
one you're doing it right and you don't
give her a reason to [ __ ] test you or
number two she just needs to she needs
to pinch herself a little bit and kind
of put a and and and just make sure okay
is this the guy that i'm meant to be
with is this guy the same
and can i have a couple examples of a
[ __ ] test that you should break up with
a girl over and a [ __ ] test that this is
how you would handle it
a breakup with a girl over in a long
term or a short-term relationship let's
say long-term because i think a lot of
my audience is looking for wives more
than short-term relationships if they
want pick up they've got a relationship
wow that's that's a very good question
um what is the kind of [ __ ] test if i
were to get a [ __ ] test
well here's the thing
a [ __ ] test is just that it's a test if
a [ __ ] test leads to a breakup in a
man's mind then chances are either you
were too weak to pass the [ __ ] test and
just didn't have it in you or what she
did was disrespect so a lot of girls
think that mentioning hey my ex texted
me today they think that's a [ __ ] test
that is not a [ __ ] test that is
disrespect if now before the
relationship you make it clear listen i
don't commit to women who stay in
contact with people who have been inside
of them so the minute she tells you hey
my text exited
my ex my text next to me my my ex texted
me and i responded and they've been
going back and forth well guess what she
just she just broke up with you because
she engaged in a behavior that makes her
a kind of woman that you don't date
so that's the kind of quote-unquote [ __ ]
test that will end the relationship her
putting herself her wanting to put your
relationship your supposed relationship
at risk and telling you about it that's
not a [ __ ] test that's disrespect yeah
that was my um
thought as well was if she's like hey
i'm going to
i'm going out to lunch with so and so
from where